[主播] 我原本其实想叫铁蛋的，我试了几个名字，铁蛋，二狗，但我发现叫二狗的时候他突然回头看我了，我觉得这个名字看有缘分啊。
[主播] 名字叫的普通一点，他应该福大命大一些。
[主播] 我在我们家，其实我妈把我叫老二。我又姐，我排第二，我还有个弟，我弟叫老三。
[主播] 叫的普通一些，这孩子应该福大命大。
[主播] 应该能过好这一生。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[嘉宾] 有朋友说你不是在介绍新生命吗？
[主播] 啊对对对，对不起，我在介绍新生命一下。
[主播] 对，我刚介绍的其实就是一种对生活的热爱。
[主播] 对吧，你说一天吃一片人生能有啥用？
[主播] 一天肯定没用。
[主播] 你要说今天吃就有用，那真的是胡说，那是心理作用。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 吃一天是心理作用。
[主播] 我相信吃的久的应该是有用的。
[主播] 反正它又不贵，一片算下来八毛钱，你抽根烟都多少钱了？
[主播] 你说呢？
[主播] 吃的时间久的应该是有用的吧，啊。
[主播] 四到五年的人身。
[主播] 而且全部取的是人身的中段。
[主播] 给你看一下它的样子，你看。
[主播] 全部人身的中段，然后用蜂蜜浸透的，吃到嘴里柔软的胶的感觉。
[主播] 像极了泡出来的陈皮，入口先是人身，这个蜂蜜的甜。
[主播] 像生活一样，先给你一点甜。
[主播] 迅速的就回味过来，人身浓郁的苦味。
[主播] 当然有味。
[主播] 因为它生长了四到五年，它要没味说明还没用呢。
[主播] 先甜后苦。
[主播] 我们其实更喜欢先苦后甜，对吧？
[主播] 从难的事情开始做，后来做容易的事情你也能接受。
[主播] 但你要一开始就从容易的事情去切入，后来你应该就不会去强求自己去做难的事情了。
[主播] 所以这是今天这个一个媒体采访我们说为什么
[主播] 俞老师要做农业，我说这俞老师个人愿望。
[主播] 然后他问我说那从你个人角度去想，为什么要做农业？
[主播] 夏季产鱼，味道不一样。
[主播] 可能就有问题。
[主播] 快递稍微碰一下，烂了，可能就有问题。
[主播] 你不像工业制品一天可以发无数单。
[主播] 农农产品今天只有三百单，只有三千单。
[主播] 多了没了。
[主播] 我说那总得有人做难的事情。
[主播] 你要从难的事情开始做啊，你会越做越容易。
[主播] 就像你小时候苦，长大了，啥苦你都能接受得了。
[主播] 小时候你生活甜如蜜啊。
[主播] 后来你就吃不了苦。
[主播] 由奢入俭。
[主播] 非常难。
[主播] 感谢大家啊。
[嘉宾] 有朋友说替我们尝尝先甜后苦啥味。
[主播] 说的对呀，我得替大家尝一下。
[嘉宾] 没了。
[嘉宾] 卖没了。
[主播] 黑吃黑。
[主播] 我以为我不用尝了。
[主播] 我要行使我作为一个农产品主播的权利。
[主播] 给大家展示一下这个人生米片，你不能加库存嘛，这个？
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[主播] 大家可以看到它的像年轮一样的样子，看到没？
[主播] 哎，灯在哪？灯在这，看到像年轮一样。
[主播] 就说明它真的是生长到四到五年的啊。
[主播] 没有了，算了。
[嘉宾] 现在可以吃。
[主播] 错过了就是错过了。
[主播] 十五岁那年。
[主播] 你因为不够勇敢。
[主播] 你错过了一份爱情。
[主播] 二十五岁那年。
[主播] 你因为不够坚定。
[主播] 你错过了一份工作。
[主播] 三十五岁那年啊。
[主播] 你因为犹豫。
[主播] 你可能还要错过一箱好吃的鸡蛋。
[主播] 只有多少箱？
[嘉宾] 我看一下只有两千。
[主播] 只有两千箱。
[嘉宾] 两千八。
[主播] 现在直播间里有三十八万人。
[主播] 你要不等我讲完再放开，要不然我还没讲它就完了。
[嘉宾] 可以，没问题。
[主播] 这个鸡蛋的一个特点大家看一下，就是高DHA。
[主播] 高DHA一般适合给谁吃？适合给孩子吃。
[主播] DHA、EPA等等这种属于Omega-3的家族。
[主播] 是人体一些关键部分的重要组成。
[主播] 它的优点我给大家看一下，比如说你看这是第一个。
[主播] 检测报告。
[主播] 大家看这是检测报告。
[主播] 检测报告这个是DHA，我们检测出来的二百五十一毫克。
[主播] 但但正常这里头。
[主播] 你看我们这给大家展示一下。
[主播] 一般情况下，我们这里的DHA含量不少于一百六十毫克，在每百克中不少于一百六十毫克。
[主播] 但这次我们所检出来其实已经到了二百五十一毫克。
[主播] 这个。
[嘉宾] 这还没谈，这还没，还没，还没，还没，还没。
[嘉宾] 这是我们新品首发。
[主播] 新品首发是吧？
[主播] 所以我刚一展示那个就是它的DHA含量不少于那个，经常会比那个多，但我确保不少于那个。
[主播] 一天两个鸡蛋，就够孩子一天的，一个青青少年一天的DHA含量了啊。
[主播] 在鸡蛋里头相对是更好吸收一些的。
[主播] 现在能上不？
[嘉宾] 我们马上给大家谈。
[主播] 好，好，好，好，好。
[嘉宾] 多少箱？有人问。
[主播] 行。
[主播] DHA还怕超标。
[主播] 好东西还怕多，对你的爱你还怕多。
[主播] DHA是好东西啊。
[嘉宾] 然后买鸡蛋的朋友说加一加会员啊。
[主播] 哎，这个加咱会员能用来买鸡蛋不？
[嘉宾] 可以啊，可以。
[主播] 可以，来来来，直播间朋友们，请大家全部点击这里，赶快现在就申请加入会员。
[主播] 这个是不是有两张券的，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 然后你一会立马就可以用它去买刚才那个鸡蛋。
[嘉宾] 对，对，对，对，对，对。
[主播] 然后买鸡蛋立马就能减，对吧？
[主播] 五块钱那个券就能用，对不对？
[嘉宾] 没错。
[主播] 感谢大家啊。
[嘉宾] 我们自营品上新，会员都会第一时间看到。
[主播] 对，我们自营品上新之后会员会第一时间看到。
[主播] 这两天的会员应该加了有百万人了吧？
[嘉宾] 两百万了。
[主播] 两百万人了。
[主播] 那咱呢，每次就三四百单，真的大家都得靠运气。
[主播] 就如果真的想吃的话啊。
[主播] 来，我这个是化了吗？袋子盒子已经烂了，不好意思啊。
[主播] 早上展示的时候还是好好的。
[主播] 填一下。
[主播] It's already cooked.
[主播] 有朋友问DHA含量高，DHA其实人体是没有办法合成DHA的。
[主播] 嗯，Omega-3家族人体没有办法合成。
[主播] 然后呢，大自然中什么DHA含量比较多，其实就是海藻。
[主播] 但这海藻其实在这个星球上生长的时间比我们长多了。
[主播] 所以现在很多比如说鸡蛋里头要有DHA就必须去去调整它很好的饲料，饲料里头具体一些这个海藻。
[主播] 但是这个海藻能不能直接吃还得捞？不行，因为有污染。
[主播] 因为海水中有很多的重金属的污染。
[主播] 所以那些海藻都是需要专门的养殖的这个罐，它在里头养殖，养殖出来的这个海藻可能就是第一个干净可以吃。
[主播] 第二个确实它的DHA含量就高了。
[主播] DHA对于小孩来说还是非常重要的。
[主播] 那个能上了吗？
[主播] 哎，不是。
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 可以的，那现在上吧。
[主播] 来，准备好，董万真选的鸡蛋。
[主播] 十五天内吃完，这箱一共是三十个，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 一箱，这箱内是三十个。
[主播] 你家早上煮，每天一到两个，你家几口人？
[主播] 其实冷冻的，就是放冰箱里一个月内都行，对吧？
[主播] 但是建议大家在两周之内吃完，因为时间久它口感可能会有影响。
[主播] 来，准备，来，三二一，上大爷。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 你看，我终于都有次在我们直播间喊三二一的机会了。
[嘉宾] 我们只有两千八百单。
[主播] 只有两千八百单，来现在还有没？
[嘉宾] 现在还没开呢。
[主播] 那现在开。
[嘉宾] 来，倒数三个数吧。
[主播] 我已经数完了。
[嘉宾] 太快了。
[嘉宾] 开了啊。
[主播] Go, please, please.
[嘉宾] 没了。
[主播] 没了吗？
[嘉宾] 没没没没没，都没了。
[主播] 不至于吧，这么快。
[嘉宾] 咱们可以在上方加一加会员啊。
[主播] 我工作这么久都终于能喊一次三二一了，我天。
[嘉宾] 都没了。
[嘉宾] 没了。
[主播] 啊？
[主播] 没了嘛？
[主播] 我还没展示呢，不是你。
[嘉宾] 但是不耽误展示，因为我们以后每天八点。
[嘉宾] 都可以抢八百单。
[主播] 每天早上八点。
[嘉宾] 八百单。
[主播] 晚上八点。
[嘉宾] 都可以抢八百单。
[嘉宾] 然后第二天刚剩下的单。
[主播] 比如说我今天晚上八点拍，你跟我发成明天早上剩的单。
[嘉宾] 八点。
[主播] 懂了。
[嘉宾] 母鸡很有压力啊，这妈的。
[主播] 没了。
[主播] 这个鸡蛋是我们有个样品，大家在收到时候这上面还打印著生产日期呢。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 上面会有个生产日期。
[主播] 然后刚才给大家说的，其实影响鸡蛋的主要的口感，包括饲料，包括鸡的品种，包括鸡的生长环境。
[主播] 我们想让孩子们吃的好一些。
[主播] 然后您在收到这个鸡蛋的时候，可以去盒子上看。
[主播] 它第一个是这个安全。
[主播] 它的刚才给大家展示完整的报告，像上面是菌，所有这些菌都检查过了。
[主播] 第二就是它的高DHA。
[主播] 这个是有行业标准的，不是说你随便说的高啊，就超过一百六十毫克的就是属于高。
[主播] 第三个就是确实好看，它是可以适合做那个糖心鸡蛋。
[主播] 因为我们就喜欢那种糖心鸡蛋嘛，对不对？
[主播] OK, OK.
[主播] 那既然都卖完了，你说这盒鸡蛋我是不是一会带走替大家尝一尝？
[主播] 来，继续下一个东西。
[嘉宾] 那下卖。
[主播] 继续卖虾是吧？
[主播] 对不起，这两天真的我们直播间里上一个东西立马卖光，上一个东西立马卖光。
[嘉宾] 小龙虾只有一万单了。
[主播] 小龙虾，你注意我们导演导演用词叫只有一万单。
[嘉宾] 大虾只有四万单。
[主播] 大虾只有四万单，直播间四十万人。
[嘉宾] 直播间四十万人。
[嘉宾] 你是让西亚文从藏胆的男人。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 来给大家叫几个单词吧。
[主播] 不能干唠嗑。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 希望大家在这里放松。
[主播] 希望大家有一种跟朋友聊天的感觉。
[主播] 虾是从哪捞的？
[主播] 厄瓜多尔海域。
[主播] 秘鲁渔场。
[主播] 对吧，四大渔场之间大家高中上课应该学过。
[主播] 北海渔场，北海到渔场，纽芬兰渔场和秘鲁渔场。
[主播] 秘鲁渔场因为靠近赤道。
[主播] 所以呢它这个海资源比较丰富。
[主播] 大部分的渔场都是从哪来的？
[主播] 大部分的渔场其实是寒暖流交会，把海底原本沉积的一些小的东西飘起来。
[主播] 那些可能在你看来就是一些沙子、石子，甚至一些小的这个珊瑚礁，对吧，一些小的这个虫子，但其实对于海里的动物来说它就是食物呀。
[主播] 我们来看一下找找到厄瓜多尔。
[主播] 来，大家看一下啊。
[主播] So this is us, right?
[主播] Here, this is us.
[主播] Beijing.
[主播] Across the planet.
[主播] To the other side.
[主播] We can see the South America.
[主播] 厄瓜多尔。
[主播] 这条一条山脉。
[主播] 有一条巨大的山脉，所以河流一般内陆河不会从这流到太平洋。
[主播] 这个巨大的山脉也挡住了来自太平洋的水气，所以其实虽然它靠近太平洋，但这里其实有很多的沙漠。
[主播] 水不会从这流到太平洋。
[主播] 所以大部分，而且又因为，因为因为，因为这个南美洲其实都是一些农业国家，所以这里的海域其实相对干净。
[主播] 干净，又靠近赤道。
[主播] 产量又大，所以这些年为什么厄瓜多尔的虾在国内会卖的这么好。
[主播] 想吃的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 对孩子来说也比较方便。
[主播] 有朋友说黄阿姨给你介绍，我也不知道这黄阿姨是谁。
[主播] 这两天所有人都再找我。
[主播] 我。
[主播] 黄阿姨说董老师好，我是黄阿姨，小伙伴让我转达他对您的喜爱。
[主播] 你注意这个用词啊。
[主播] 他对你的喜爱和他对您的喜爱是不一样的。
[主播] 你你你听懂这其中的差距不？
[主播] 我不知道你们能听懂不？
[主播] 就比如说对对对顿顿和东东杰西这样帅哥来说，是他对你的喜爱。
[主播] 一提到有东东就是对您的喜爱。
[主播] 你仔细听啊。
[主播] 我都把你尊尊为您了，你能懂我的意思吗？
[主播] 要不然咱俩就做个兄妹吧。
[主播] 就那种感觉。
[嘉宾] 啊？
[嘉宾] 心怀你。
[嘉宾] 好油啊。
[嘉宾] 单结游戏。
[主播] 我有过这种经验。
[主播] 他当时很感动说董宇辉你这么聪明，这么努力，这么幽默，还这么勤奋。
[主播] 你真好。
[主播] 我当时很开心。
[主播] 我说说下去。
[主播] 他说所以咱俩做兄妹吧。
[主播] 我懂你们。
[主播] 懂你们。
[主播] 你们只是想靠近我。
[主播] 但你们又不想陪伴我，我懂你们。
[主播] 你言人总分分合合。
[主播] 兄妹才相伴一生啊，你不就是更长久的图我吗？
[主播] 我懂。
[主播] 来，下一个产品啊。
[主播] 黑豆粉，真的我们这两天实在没东西卖了。
[主播] 疯狂卖黑豆粉。
[主播] 希望你早餐吃的健康啊。
[主播] 朋友说好人卡。
[主播] 你能想像为什么，为什么现在董宇辉就是面对大家对于我样貌的攻击。
[主播] 对于我口音的羞辱。
[主播] 对于我很多批评的，我已经可以风轻云淡的跟你聊天了。
[主播] I'm I've had enough of it.
[主播] 有的人的青春的回忆起来全是故事。
[主播] 他们时常会感伤。
[主播] 因为他们怀念旧的时代，在旧的时代里头他们过得更开心一些。
[主播] Like the glory days.
[主播] 你一去先，整天都是梦回大唐。
[主播] 怀念那个时代。
[主播] 有的人的青春呢是是故事。
[主播] 我的青春呢看起来更像事故。
[主播] 同样收到一封信，有的人翻开了之后是惊喜。
[主播] 我那个信啊，一般不用翻开，因为我知道肯定是惊吓。
[主播] 就是年少时期多受一点苦。
[主播] 所以长大了之后就多了一份理性。
[主播] 一般不苛求别人。
[主播] 只责自己。
[主播] 以数己之心数人，以责己之心责己。
[主播] 就豁然开朗了。
[主播] 倒不是因为总是我错。
[主播] 主要原因是因为我想放过自己。
[主播] 想拍的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 这个对，我在卖的是核桃粉啊。
[主播] 这个里头有核桃，黑大豆。
[主播] 黑芝麻，黑藜麦。
[主播] 奇亚子以及黑米。
[主播] 咱今天玩那些书能不能让我讲会书呀？
[主播] 我今天早上拿那么多书呢。
[嘉宾] 我们在谈库存，如果有库存了马上就可以。
[主播] 晚清之后十八年。
[嘉宾] 没问题。
[主播] 可以卖吗现在？
[嘉宾] 我们谈库存，谈到了马上讲。
[主播] 就现在我先讲，你再谈，谈到了我再卖，行不行？
[嘉宾] 我们看没有。
[嘉宾] 一万单库存。
[主播] 卖书也是货呀，精神食粮也是食粮。
[主播] 再忍一会。
[主播] 大家再给我一会时间。
[主播] 好吧？
[主播] 再给我一会时间。
[主播] 我已经按耐不住我内心的激动了。
[主播] 有朋友说这个董老师，我要跟你在一起，你别这样伤害自己。
[主播] 答应我，找个帅的，男人都靠不住。
[主播] 还不如找个帅的。
[嘉宾] 你问你，你讲完之后就可以讲那本书了。
[嘉宾] 我们谈了一万单库存。
[主播] 一万单库存，什么书？
[嘉宾] 就是晚清之后十八年。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 拿来。
[嘉宾] 你进来没讲。
[主播] 我讲完了。
[主播] 大家自己去买，听话。
[主播] 不要让大人操心，你都多大了，你还让我操心，多大人了？
[主播] 老让我操心，你让我操心到啥时候？
[主播] 终于能让我讲会书了。
[主播] 来。
[主播] 这个你给我一些纸，我把桌子擦干净，不能把书弄脏了。
[主播] 菜能脏了可以洗，书弄脏了你咋洗？
[嘉宾] 只有一万单。
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 谢谢大家。
[主播] 谢谢大家，终于可以让我卖会书了。
[主播] 所以你看我也其实一直是在自己的舒适区里啊。
[主播] 一个老师不就是爱。
[主播] 后辈人师吗？
[主播] 尤其像我这种，对吧，脑袋空空的，胡说八道。
[主播] 啊，张嘴就来。
[主播] 那你让我讲书我是不是很舒服？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 所以很多朋友说董宇辉你为什么在镜头前很放松？
[主播] 因为我在做自己擅长的事情。
[主播] 晚清之后十八年。
[主播] 你给我找个世界，我把桌子再擦一下，一会把书弄脏了。
[主播] 手可以脏，书不能脏。
[主播] 这本书是黄志军写的。
[主播] 其实在明清的这个历史研究啊，近些年是很受欢迎的，以前人们研究明清研究的少一些。
[主播] 晚清之后十八年，其实写的是从袁世凯。
[主播] 来，没事没事。
[主播] 你看，帅哥出镜了，大家看一下我们公司长得帅的都被雪藏了。
[主播] 东东。
[嘉宾] 没过两天我就回来了。
[主播] 东方东东。
[主播] 就是因为他过分帅气，所以总是被公司雪藏。
[主播] 然后出现在屏幕前的全是我这样的歪瓜裂枣。
[主播] 为啥？
[主播] 改天等你们见到我们公司CEO的长相之后，你就恍然大明白。
[主播] 长得帅的必须雪藏，不能威胁到他。
[主播] 来。
[主播] 给大家讲讲这个啊。
[主播] 你看你看你看评论区这些人，你看评论区这些人，这些人说让他回来，让他回来。
[嘉宾] 他俩都是好好的。
[主播] 你要不回来坐这。
[主播] 他们想你。
[嘉宾] 如果不想过就下播了。
[主播] 来，大家，晚清之后十八年，我讲讲书，讲讲书。
[主播] 这本书讲的是袁世凯从这个朝鲜回来之后，开始发生的事情。
[主播] 我们现在再去经常回忆袁世凯的时候，其实有经常我们是没有办法在那个角度去看他的。
[主播] 当然这本书它还算是比较写实。
[主播] 这本书我整个读完之后，因为故事性比较强，我现在不能完整给大家讲完。
[主播] 我只能说我当时在西安学校很早的时候，孙老师让我们读这本书。
[主播] 我读完这本书就就我印象特别深刻的其实就是甲午海战那一刻。
[主播] 当时呢其实以这个海军的舰艇的排水的能力那个量来说，其实它可以在全球排到第五或第六。
[主播] 它其实很强大。
[主播] 但是一战击败。
[主播] 一战击败的原因就是描述已经到了战场上了，那些人还在思前想后。
[主播] 八国联军已经清华了，朝中各派内斗。
[主播] 大家没有坚定地去同仇敌忾。
[主播] 大家在那一刻心里想的也不是如何打赢一场战争。
[主播] 大家想的一方面我的船不能打沉，因为多年经营不能一朝全部毁废湮灭。
[主播] 船，我不能输，我不能被别人拿沉。
[主播] 第二个我也不可能一战全胜，因为一旦胜了以后没有了外部威胁，那师傅也就不需要李中堂。
[主播] 所以这本书我当时读到之后读的先是纠结，后来是愤怒，读完愤怒之后呢，其实是一种豁然开朗的清醒。
[主播] 所以我前几天提到这本书的时候，我说了一段话，我说。
[主播] 我说正确的初衷才是最强大的力量。
[主播] 很多人想听这段，大家可以开始录屏了。
[主播] 你准备好录屏的回复一，我开始给你讲我关于这本书提炼的核心观点啊。
[主播] 你准备好录屏的回复一，好吧？
[嘉宾] 有朋友说卖点盗版书吧，太贵了。
[主播] 我不能这样子。
[主播] 我如果只是一个想挣投机的想挣钱的人我会做，但是如果我是一个真正知识分子，我不愿意那样做。
[主播] 我如果只是一个想挣投机的想挣钱的人我会做，但是如果我是一个真正
[主播] 知识分子，我不愿意那样做，我宁愿自己多花点钱去买书。
[主播] 如果我们都去卖盗版的话，那以后谁还会花心思去研究？
[主播] 没有人研究还有谁去著书立作？
[主播] 抄袭是最容易的方式，但抄袭是从根本上伤害了创新的最直接的方式。
[主播] 晚清最后18年这套书讲的是从袁世凯，袁世凯从朝鲜回来之后发生的事情。
[主播] 这本书非常打动我的就是在北洋水师甲午海战的时候，当时强盛的帝国从来没有想到自己在一个弹丸小国面前输的如此颜面尽失。
[主播] 其实并不是因为他不过强大。
[主播] 后人在总结历史的时候，总事看不清全貌，觉得是我们太弱小了，如果当时用来买更多的舰艇会不会好一些？
[主播] 我相信这本书能给你一个清晰的答案。
[主播] 就是已经到了战场上，各方势力仍然在角逐。
[主播] 已经到了关键的要分胜负的时候，大家心里仍然没有坚定决心去作战。
[主播] 大家想的是多年经营的李中堂，如此强大的北洋水师，这么多舰艇都是白花花的银子。
[主播] 我不能输。
[主播] 一旦输了打沉了，钱白花了。
[主播] 第二个我也不会赢。
[主播] 因为赢了之后，没有了外部威胁之后，北洋水师是否还有存在的必要性？
[主播] 一群军人不考虑军人的问题。
[主播] 一群大臣不考虑大臣的问题。
[主播] 这就是那个时代的悲哀，所以那个时代注定的悲哀，
[主播] 就是因为在其岗位却不考虑他岗位的职责。
[主播] 所以我当时读完这本书之后，就告诉了孩子们一段话。
[主播] 好多年前在西安新东方的课堂上，我给孩子们说，正确的初衷才是最强大的力量。
[主播] 请你记住，它胜过一切高超的智慧和任何细腻的手法。
[主播] 只有最强大的力量才能支撑你走到最后。
[主播] 那些心怀不轨的人，那些不忠诚于使命的人，
[主播] 那些从一开始就没有正确出心的人，他可能会靠著自己的小聪明蒙骗一时，
[主播] 但大多数会在黎明前倒下。
[主播] 就算有那么一两个幸运的，好像多走了几步，
[主播] 那他会更尴尬。
[主播] 因为他会在太阳正头顶的时候，于众目睽睽之下倒在你面前。
[主播] 他不仅输，他还输的会更加彻底。
[主播] 所以这套书在当年我特别年轻的时候，我觉得他也从很大一个程度上纠正了我的价值观。
[主播] 或者说加强了我的价值观，最后影响了我的价值观。
[主播] 正确的初衷才是最强大的力量。
[主播] 永远不要忘记你为什么出发。
[主播] 当一个人开始背弃自己理想的时候，他不会成功的。
[主播] 他再聪明都不会成功的。
[主播] 他拥有
[主播] 困难。
[主播] 但请你三观不改。
[主播] 这就是为什么我向屏幕前的每个朋友推荐晚清最后18年。
[主播] 它应该有两本书。
[主播] 是吧？这好像是个改编版，我当时读的一共会有四本。
[主播] 这是
[主播] 精华版是吧？
[主播] 那可能就故事更加的集中一些，也挺好，也挺好。
[主播] 读一些精华版，大家可能时间也更加快一些。
[主播] 除了这个还有那本呢，是这个吗？
[主播] 对，这是两本书啊。
[主播] 晚清最后18年，推荐给屏幕前的每一个朋友。
[主播] 我刚所说的这个正确的初衷，其实就是你为什么而出发。
[主播] 在商业世界里头就是你要解决什么问题？
[主播] 在具体岗位上就是你要创造什么价值？
[主播] 在家庭里头就是你为什么在奋斗？
[主播] 每一个环节里都可以去问一问自己，什么才是你真正正确的初衷？
[主播] 这个很重要。
[主播] 就是
[主播] what do you fight for,你在捍卫什么？
[主播] 你在捍卫什么？
[主播] your mission,
[主播] 你的使命感是什么？
[主播] your goal,
[主播] 你的目标是什么？
[主播] 这些很重要。
[主播] 只有正确的使命，正确的目标才会给你足够多的内驱力，drive,足够多的内驱力。
[主播] 足够多的内驱力才会让你走得很远，而且走得很稳妥。
[主播] 大家见过很多聪明人，依靠自己的聪明，一招取胜的故事，很多对吧？
[主播] 太多这种投机取巧的故事，会让一个时代变得轻浮。
[主播] 罗翔有句话说这个
[主播] 来得晚的正义算不算正义？
[主播] 有很多人讨论过这个问题。
[主播] 算正义。
[主播] 只要来了就行。
[主播] 所以我们也见过太多最后因为比如说德不配位发生的事情。
[主播] 那其实在这个晚清最后18年这套书里头，我认为其实给了我们同样讨论的问题。
[主播] 就是作为一个我们普通的人，你在自己的岗位上也同样可以讨论这个问题。
[主播] 你为什么而努力，你要解决什么样的问题？
[主播] 我觉得这套书特别值得每个人去看一看。
[主播] 我觉得那些强大的正确的初衷，永远像正头顶12点时候发出的太阳光一样，强烈刺眼。
[主播] 让你无法躲藏。
[主播] 请你必须记住你为什么而出发。
[主播] 永远不要忘记。
[主播] 永远不要背弃你的信仰。
[主播] 我们只有3000本。
[主播] 只有3000本。
[主播] 可以给书切个镜头吗？可以。
[主播] 看这。
[主播] 它是一个全新的修订版。
[主播] 我当年买的那个呢是当时一共会有四套，这个修订版之后应该就是成了两套了。
[主播] 它可能就内容更加集中一些。
[主播] 黄志军在写这套书的时候，他的生活其实当时也遇见了很多的困难。
[主播] 开始写于2011年。
[主播] 然后他在写这块的时候，他的舅舅给他打电话，他哥得了一种病。
[主播] 然后去治病了。
[主播] 他哥开了一个塑料厂，然后资产做的很高。
[主播] 但是后来呢，这个生了病。
[主播] 他也是在那样生活本身不乐观的情况下，遇见了很多现实困难的情况下，
[主播] 写了这套书。
[主播] 他写这套书的序言前面有这段话，我印象特别深刻。
[主播] 说
[主播] 观潮过后，他的心情仍然久久不能平静。
[主播] 他觉得他应该写点什么。
[主播] 孙文。
[主播] 三一烟菜。
[主播] 就是大家熟悉的另一个名字，那是一个日本朋友帮他起的。
[主播] 翻译孙中山。
[主播] 似乎看到了一种人间最本质的东西。
[主播] 这也是我们最终要讲述的历史规律。
[主播] 世界潮流。
[主播] 浩浩荡荡。
[主播] 顺之者昌。
[主播] 逆之者亡。
[主播] 你看完这套书，你可能在下次再学到历史的时候，再听到那些历史人物的时候，
[主播] 你可能会带著一个新的视角。
[主播] 你可能就能理解为什么我们那段时间会有那么多的屈辱。
[主播] 我四万万同胞，为何和精神那些屈辱？
[主播] 正确的初衷才是最强大的力量，胜过任何高超的智慧和细腻的手法。
[主播] 唯有正确的初衷能够让你走到最后。
[主播] 心怀不轨者，
[主播] 注定失败。
[主播] 晚清最后18年。
[主播] 没有了。
[主播] 自己去拍啊。
[主播] 四万万，对，四万万同胞啊。
[主播] 这个书特别好，我当年看他。
[主播] 不忘初心啊。
[主播] 所以现在我们经常去听不忘初心。
[主播] 就是一直在提醒你，四万万同胞啊，不好意思，我刚说错了。
[主播] 来，下一个给大家下一个东西。
[主播] 三胖的瓜子，我第一次吃这瓜子的时候觉得配不上，这瓜子很贵。
[主播] 来，想买的自己去拍啊。
[主播] 这个瓜子确实价格比较高，我就不强烈推荐了。
[主播] 但是它确实好吃。
[主播] 然后呢，
[主播] 如果你自己想吃，你就拍。
[主播] 如果你觉得价格太高，你不买了也行。